[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan
and I'm coming to you
from the Google Launchpad
space in San Francisco.
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Android 7.1 Developer
Preview is coming soon
and it has some cool new stuff,
including the App Shortcuts
API as well as the
Storage Manager Intent.
To learn more about
the update as well as
get your phone ready
with the Beta channel,
follow the link in the post.
PicMix is a photo
and video editing
app with 27 million
users worldwide,
65% of which are outside of
its home market in Indonesia.
Follow the link
in the description
below to hear the CEO
and the co-founder
explain how they use Google
Play tools, such as store
listen experiments
and material design,
to create a high
quality app which
appeals to a global audience.
You can now deploy and
operate Pivotal Cloud Foundry
on Google Cloud Platform,
which means Cloud Foundry
applications can utilize Google
Cloud load balancing, fast boot
times on virtual
machines, and industry
leading price-to-performance
ratio on Cloud Compute
resources.
For details and to get
started, check out the post.
There is now an integrated code
editor as part of Google Cloud
Shell, the command
line interface
to manage Google Cloud
Platform resources.
The editor is based
on Eclipse Orion
and it lets you edit code
and configuration files
without leaving your browser.
Get started with the post.
65% of consumers
say they'd consider
using messaging to connect with
a business to get information
about a product or
service or to schedule
an in-person appointment.
And so in the
coming weeks, we're
introducing a
Click-to-Message Ads
to bring the efficiency
and effectiveness
of messaging to search ads.
More details on how this
works, including screenshots,
head on over to the post.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I'm Timothy Jordan and you
just watched an episode
of the Developer Show.
To catch some of our
previous episodes,
click right here or right
here, this one's a good one.
That's cool, I'll wait.